S
AMERICA LAST POLICY.
>> Sean: APPRECIATE YOU BEING
WITH US.
TONIGHT WHILE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE LACK OF INCLUSION IN THE
TALIBAN'S A NEW GOVERNMENT WE
ARE GETTING A PICTURE OF WHAT
THE TALIBAN WILL BE LIKE UNDER
TALIBAN RULE WHERE SHARIA LAW OR
RULES SUPREME.
AFGHAN WOMEN WILL SOON BE BANNED
FROM PLAYING SPORTS, HOLDING
MOST JOBS, THEIR TRAVEL WILL
ALSO BE RESTRICTED, MOST MUSIC
IS ALSO GOING TO BE BANNED,
COMEDY IS BANNED AND ALL WOMEN
WILL BE FORCED TO ADHERE TO A
STRICT DRESS CODE AND MORAL
CODE.
THE PUNISHMENT FOR BREAKING ANY
OF THESE BARBARIC RULES IS
DEATH.
HERE WITH MORE, THE HOST OF
FOX NATION, LARRA LOGAN ALONG
WITH THE MEDAL OF HONOR
RECIPIENT, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TO KOTA MYERS IS US.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS OUR
INTELLIGENCE WAS ABLE TO TRACK
THE TERRORIST ATTACK THAT KILLED
13 AMERICANS AND INJURED 200
MORE AND KILLED OVER 100 MORE,
AND THEY HAD, THEY RAN UP THE
CHAIN.
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS HAPPENING,
THE INTEL WAS EXACTLY RIGHT AND
THEY HAD THE ABILITY TO TAKE
THIS GUY OUT.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN SAYS THE
PENTAGON DENIES THIS REPORT AND
THEY DIDN'T TAKE OUT THE SUICIDE
BOMBER.
YOU'VE BEEN LOOKING INTO IT, I
HEARD YOU THIS MORNING TALKING
ABOUT IT, WHAT IS THE LATEST ON
IT?
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
TELLING US THE TRUTH OR ARE THEY
LYING?
>> ARE WE GOING TO TRUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, ARE WE
ACTUALLY GOING TO TRUST THE
PEOPLE PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHO CONTINUE TO
LIE TO US?
NO, TALKING TO THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND, WE HAVE CONFIRMED WITH
THREE DIFFERENT SOURCES THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN THIS THAT SET
IT UP, INTEL REPORTING THAT
THERE WAS GOING TO BE AN ATTACK,
THAT THEY FOUND THIS PERSON,
THEY ACTUALLY HAD DRONE LOCK ON
THIS PERSON, THEY SET IT UP AND
REQUESTED TO TAKE THE SHOT AND
THE RESPONSE WAS NO FOR THE
REASON BEING THEY WERE
NEGOTIATING, IN NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE TALIBAN.
THIS IS COMING DIRECTLY FROM
SOURCES ON THE GROUND, SERVICES
WHO WERE ACTUALLY INVOLVED IN
THIS INCIDENT.
SO OF COURSE, DO YOU EXPECT THE
GOVERNMENT TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF THEY ACTUALLY ADMITTED
TO THIS.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO YOU,
LARRA LOGAN.
WE KNOW WHAT LIFE WAS LIKE FOR
WOMEN UNDER THE TALIBAN BEFORE.
WE'VE SEEN THESE REPORTS, WE
KNOW WHAT THEY SAY THEY ARE
GOING TO DO.
I GUESS THE OBVIOUS QUESTION IS
WHY WOULD ANYONE EXPECT ANYTHING
DIFFERENT?
AND THE IDEA THAT TONY BLINKEN
IS SO OUT OF TOUCH WITH WHO THE
TALIBAN REALLY IS AND THEY FORCE
YOUNG GIRLS INTO SEX SLAVERY AND
MARRIAGE AND SUBJUGATE WOMEN SO
THEY CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL OR WORK
IN THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT AND THEY ARE SAYING THEY
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
INCLUSIVITY AND THE GOVERNMENT
OF THE TALIBAN, HOW DUMB ARE
THESE PEOPLE NOT TO KNOW THE
TALIBAN FOR WHO THEY ARE?
>> IT'S NOT STUPIDITY, THEY KNOW
EXACTLY WHO THE TALIBAN ARE.
THEY ARE COUNTING ON THE FACT
THAT AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
WHO THE TALIBAN ARE COMMON TO
SELL YOU A PACK OF LIES AND THIS
DIDN'T STOP WITH TONY BLINKEN.
THIS STARTED WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU CAN GO ALL THE WAY BACK TO
RIGHT AFTER OBAMA WAS ELECTED,
THIS WAS THE MESSAGE FROM THE
VERY, VERY BEGINNING, THAT THERE
IS GOOD TALIBAN AND BAD TALIBAN.
THEY PACKED THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH APOLOGIST AND JUST IGNORED
ALL THE EVIDENCE.
THE TALIBAN HAS HAD CONTROL OVER
LIMITED PARTS OF AFGHANISTAN AND
THEIR RULE HAS BEEN IDENTICAL TO
WHAT YOU ARE SEEING NOW.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF THEY
DIDN'T KNOW, THEY HAD ALL THE
EVIDENCE.
I RECEIVED TODAY FOOTAGE OF
YOUNG WOMEN IN PROTESTS WHICH I
THINK ARE IN KABUL.
I WILL RELEASE THAT WHEN I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO VENT IT TO KNOW FOR
SURE ABOUT GUN FIRE OUTCOME OF
THESE WOMEN